No matter how violent, depraved, or overtly
sexual a video game is, rallying the public
in an effort to censor a title will always
bring more attention to the game in question.
If you tell the gaming audience that they
can't play a game, they're going to want to
play it.
"So tell your folks 'Buy me Bonestorm or go
to hell!'"
Here are a few examples when video game censorship
went very wrong.
Death Race
If you think public outrage over video games
is a modern thing, think again.
Exidy's Death Race is a 1976 arcade title
in which players zoom around a black and white
screen, running over stick figures to gain
points.
Officially, the creatures are "gremlins,"
but there's little difference between a monster
and a normal human being in the space of a
few pixels.
Death Race wasn't anything special, but once
the Associated Press ran an article about
it, weirdly comparing the game's digital beeps
to the "scream of a child," it was off to
the digital races.
After that, various articles denounced the
game as "sick" and "morbid," and called for
its removal from arcades.
The end result?
Death Race sold very, very well, and in 1976,
Exidy made $3 million thanks to Death Race
alone.
Exidy released games until 1989, and violent
video games were here to stay.
Mortal Kombat
Way back in the early '90s, Nintendo controlled
90 percent of the United States' video game
market… but it had powerful rival.
Sega managed to create a unique niche for
itself by promoting their 16-bit Sega Genesis
as a more mature, edgier product than the
Super Nintendo, which was portrayed as family-friendly
toy.
Enter: the notoriously bloody fighting game,
Mortal Kombat.
"Johnny Cage Wins!"
After a successful arcade release, both Nintendo
and Sega had to make a choice when it came
to their console editions: to censor, or not
to censor?
Sega went for blood, albeit in a roundabout
way, with an easy-to-remember cheat code to
unlock the game's gore, but Nintendo kept
it clean.
"Finish her!"
As a result, the Genesis version of Mortal
Kombat sold more copies than its Nintendo
cousin, inadvertently proving Sega's point.
The Genesis really was the system to usher
in the next era of gaming.
Night Trap
There's only one reason you've heard of Night
Trap, and it's not because the 1992 full-motion
video game is any good.
'I'm so confused!
What's going on?"
In 1993, when the United States Senate held
a hearing about the effect of video games
on players, politicians singled out Night
Trap and Mortal Kombat as particularly egregious
examples of video game violence.
"The second game is Night Trap, which is a
game set in a sorority house.
The object is to keep hooded men from hanging
the young woman with a hook…"
Complaints from parents followed, and Sega
pulled Night Trap from store shelves right
before Christmas, promising to release a censored
version down the line.
But instead of keeping the content under wraps,
the Senate hearings boosted the game's profile
on a national scale.
When Night Trap came out for PC and Mac in
1994, Digital Pictures specifically used the
controversy as a selling point.
The real kicker?
The ESRB, which was founded as a direct response
to these Senate hearings, rated the upcoming
Night Trap remaster "T for Teen": appropriate
for players 13 and up.
Manhunt
Rockstar Games is well-acquainted with controversy,
being the folks behind the Grand Theft Auto
series and all, but despite critics' claims,
Grand Theft Auto doesn't force you to run
over hookers or innocent pedestrians.
For the most part, the only people that you
have to kill are other criminals.
Rockstar's Manhunt is different.
Speaking to GamesRadar, a former Rockstar
employee revealed the game's troubled history,
revealing that company employees threatened
to mutiny because of the game's excessively
violent content, saying,
"With GTA, we always had the excuse that the
gameplay was untethered….
You could play completely ethically if you
wanted."
"Manhunt, though, just made us all feel icky.
It was all about the violence, and it was
realistic violence."
The rest of the world responded similarly.
Politicians introduced legislation to fine
retailers that sold mature games to kids.
And after an alleged Manhunt fan murdered
a 14-year-old with a hammer, mimicking one
of Manhunt's grisly kills, some stores pulled
the game entirely.
When Rockstar decided to press ahead with
an even more depraved sequel, they didn't
even have to do much marketing.
As the New York Times noted,
"Manhunt 2 has received free publicity and
media attention it would have never enjoyed
were it not for the presumably unwitting complicity
of the ratings boards and self-appointed media
watchdogs."
"It is called Manhunt 2.
And we must warn you, there is nothing about
this that is not disturbing."
HuniePop
It's not just violence that attracts censors;
sex is a big problem, too, especially in North
America.
Take HuniePop, for example: a game that fuses
match-three puzzles with a visual novel.
But it also asks the player to seduce a variety
of anime women.
Succeed, and you'll not only get down with
your digital lady, but you'll also unlock
some explicit illustrations.
Critics begrudgingly agree that it's a good
puzzle game, but at its core, it's pretty
clearly cartoon porn.
While HuniePop is right at home among the
visual novels produced in Japan, it's awfully
racy for mainstream American outlets, and
it's been both banned from Twitch and heavily
censored on Steam.
But that controversy also generated awareness:
HuniePop moved around 540,000 copies in its
edit form, which isn't bad for a niche title.
Of course, there's a catch: shortly after
HuniePop arrived on Steam, the game's developers
released a free patch that restored the hidden
content, voiding the Steam-imposed censorship
after all.
Point: perverts.
Postal 2
The difference that censorship made for the
Postal franchise is clear.
The first Postal received mediocre reviews
and didn't make much of an impact, aside from
an attempted ban championed by senator Joe
Lieberman.
Its sequel, Postal 2, spawned a feature film
spinoff, broke sales records, and continues
to receive expansion packs and new content
from its developer, even though the game is
15 years old.
So, what changed?
The New Zealand government succeeded in banning
Postal 2 on the grounds that
"...the game is designed, and has the capacity,
to allow the player to test how much violence
and humiliation he or she can inflict on human
beings."
Australia refused to certify the game, effectively
making it illegal in the country.
The Swedish government tried and failed to
sue Postal 2's local distributor for selling
violent content.
All of these things just ended up promoting
the game.
Postal 2 even received an expansion pack in
2015, and a modern remaster of the first game
arrived in 2016.
Plans for Postal 4 are reportedly under way—and,
if history is any indication, it'll freak
out people all over again.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!